mit die länder bekommt unsere erde
einen neuen kontinent dabei lag der
vollständig von wasser bedeckt und etwa
allzu große kontinent wie australien
die ganze zeit direkt vor unseren augen
mitten im pazifischen ozean
was genau mit der landmasse passierte
als sie fast unterging und welche
antworten dieser mysteriöse achter
kontinent noch auf die großen rätsel
unserer erde geben könnte erfahrt ihr
jetzt im krieg zum feind fixen herzlich
willkommen
schon lange lag die länder direkt vor
unseren augen doch die landmasse unter
neuseeland erfüllte in den augen der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nicht alle kriterien eines kontinent
lange dachten sie dass die größte von
wil ende ja nicht komplett zusammen
hängt ein trugschluss der jetzt
aufgedeckt werden konnte und die länder
tatsächlich von einem auf den anderen
tag zum achten kontinent unserer erde
beförderte das geschrei februar
allerdings dem geologen das etwas
genauer und sprechen von einem wippten
kontinent europa und asien haben eine
zusammenhängende erdkruste und werden
so als ein großer kontinent nämlich
eurasien angesehen so oder so will ende
hat unserem planeten um einen kontinent
reicher gemacht sensationell bisher
wissen wir was die länder zu 93 prozent
oder verliert und sich unter neuseeland
und neukaledonien über zwei tektonische
platten erstreckt vor rund 85 millionen
jahren soll sich die länder von auch
reihen der antarktis und wlan ja selbst
die bislang ein und den selben kontinent
gebildet hatten abgespeichert haben
diese abspaltung selbst soll dafür
gesorgt haben dass sich die landmasse
von willem ja stark in die länge
gezogen hat nicht verdünnt und somit
halb im wasser unterging die entdeckung
die länder zeigt mal wieder dass wir
noch längst nicht alles über unseren
planeten herausgefunden haben und dass
es noch sehr viele spannende dinge zu
entdecken gibt auch die länder selbst
liegt noch viele rätsel auf und so hat
sich ende juli diesen jahres ein
forscherteam aus australien auf den weg
gemacht um unseren neuen fast
versunkenen kontinent zu erforschen
expeditionen 371 ist die erste forschung
diese art der plan der forscherinnen und
forscher ist es an sechs verschiedenen
orten östlich von australien nach
proben zu bohren
aus bis zu 8000 metern tiefe sollen
gesteins pro mhz ans tageslicht
gefördert werden die gemeinde aus
vergangenen zeit sparen begriffe und
mikro fossilien könnten viele spannende
hinweise auf die großen rätsel unseres
planeten geben welche gebiete des
kontinents ging wann genau unser und
raten wann genau wieder aus dem wasser
heraus die antworten auf diese fragen
liefert die forscherinnen und forscher
eventuell besser verstehen wie volkan
ketten
entstanden sind oder wie die
plattentektonik der erde vonstatten geht
aber auch die klimatische entwicklung
unseres planeten könnte durch die
analyse der gesteinsschichten weiter
aufgeschlüsselt werden
hierbei geht es um erfahrene dazu
natürlich immer das neuste werk ein
video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt also dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit woher kommt das
wasser auf der erde super interessantes
video verklagte draufklicken und viel
spaß dabei und ansonsten bedankt